Now it's time to launch a settings
activity from the menu item.
We need to launch it from two places,
the Main Activity and
the Detail Activity.
Afterwards, compile and
run the app to make sure that it works.
This is what it should
look like from the.
Main Activity,
if you tap on Settings menu,
it should be bring you to
the Settings Activity.
It is expected for it to be blank,
because we haven't populated it yet.
Now let's try the Detail Activity.
If you tap on a Forecast,
you can go into the Detail Activity and
then you can go into
the Settings Activity.
Complete the task and then verify
that your app behavior is like this.
In the directions that
I just provided and
in the following videos of this course,
you'll notice that the settings
activity had an action bar
at the top of the screen.
When building your app with the latest
version of the Support library,
the action bar doesn't show up by
default in the Settings Activity.
As a result, it's expected and
correct that your device looks
like this with no action bar.
Don't worry, we'll add the action
bar back when we change the theme of
the Settings Activity in lesson five.
For more info,
check the instructor notes.